this is a new camp for internally
displaced people in the somali capital
mogadishu
most of these families are from lower
chebele which is on the brink of a
famine
muhammad hussein is worried about his
son the little boy doesn't have anything
to eat and some of the other children
have measles
we left our home and lived in hard
conditions
just the other day my daughter died of
measles
my son is sick and is getting worse we
lost everything in the drought
four rainy seasons have failed in the
horn of africa humanitarian groups
estimate more than 18 million people are
going hungry in somalia ethiopia
djibouti and kenya
a combination of armed conflicts rising
global food and fuel prices has worsened
the impact of the extreme weather on
poor communities somali is the on the
front line of the
climate change currently it's
frankly the second most vulnerable
country in terms of vulnerability for
climate change
leaders from the region are meeting to
coordinate ahead of a broader u.n
climate summit in november governments
from the region
want to bring this to the attention of
the negotiators at cop 27 the climate
negotiations happening in sherman sheikh
and today they've adopted a historic
declaration to that effect that will be
brought to to the negotiators
muhammad does not need to be reminded
about the devastating effects of climate
change he's less concerned about the
decisions leaders make at their summits
and more worried about where his next
meal will come from catherine soy al
jazeera